welcome to simply learn we are honored
to have you join us today for the future
of big data with your host saeed
my name is richard and after this intro
i'll be mostly in the background helping
syed so that everything moves smoothly
the future of big data as information
technologies world explodes the
opportunities and growth in big data
field explode with it there's more
information generated already this year
than the sum of all previous years
sorting it all out making sense of it is
big data and having a clue to the future
of big data helps to open up career
professional opportunities
if you do not know syed
syed is a big data and hadoop consultant
working with best in town analytics uh
erica and simply learn a hadoop expert
with the background is a senior software
engineer and project lead he carries
certifications and expertise in apache
hadoop the data scientist toolbox
mongodb getting and cleaning data r
programming pmp and exploratory data
analysis for the last half a decade
basically everything big data i'm
excited to have syed here today
for those who aren't familiar with this
form of webinar i want to introduce you
to your dashboard or control panel
if everyone could locate your dashboard
and then locate the question module
go ahead and message hello in the
question model module just say hi to
syed let us know you're excited to be
here this also lets us know that you're
hearing us and everything is connected
correctly
great i got
oops
melanie great to have you uh
shukla i hope i'm saying that right
hello yes um you won't be able to hear
me because you're going to be on mute so
you want to use a question bar
um great to have you
sobranzit i hope i'm saying that
correctly also great to have everybody
aboard
if it is a if you have a specific
question on your career or real world
journey post it in here in the question
module
this question module is your best friend
at the end of the presentation we'll
have a 15-minute q a
and that time we'll try to cover all the
questions that are asked in the module
some of them might be covered during the
session but generally we try to answer
them at the end
you didn't come here oh yeah you didn't
come here listen to me speak i'm proud
to introduce syed who will be your host
for the future of big data go ahead and
sit back relax have a cup of coffee tea
or if it's in the evening where you're
at maybe a glass of merlot
and enjoy it's an honor for me to hand
this over to syed thank you and happy
learning syed
yep ferdinand how are you doing
i'm doing excellent today how are you
doing
i'm doing fantastic thank you so much
for asking
uh this is one thing richard i cannot
see questions uh coming up on my window
in my question window
so
do you or i can somebody want to want to
check it i'm not able to see any
questions from any of the participants
let me um go ahead they should come up
my heavy down is presenter everything
looks right on my side let me go ahead
i can see it now okay excellent i'm
going to go ahead and meet myself and
let you take over all right thanks
excellent thank you so much richard
and uh well once again welcome uh all of
you all hopefully you guys are able to
hear my voice and see my screen uh
and once again thank you so much richard
for giving that wonderful presentation
about myself
um somebody's asking me what the webinar
exactly going to be this webinar is
about a little bit about big data
technology technology technologies
now that we've uh passed the majority of
uh this year 2016. the future as it is
going to be for next up you know couple
of years um so that is what the you know
webinars are you know all about
hi
uh all of you all let me just uh come
out of this
screen and introduce you to my cheat
sheet so uh any one of you who have been
like attending my presentation yeah you
know you would know that my
presentations or my batches or my
classes would know that i usually use
this kind of cheat sheet
wherein i
you know less than all the topics you
know keep typing it over here and then
keep keep
keep explaining the concepts keep on
toggling between my this little window
over here and uh
with the presentation i keep completing
topics and i keep coming with uh coming
back to the seed and keep marking it as
done like that as the my introduction
has been done
uh wonderfully well by richard just now
amazing so that's where we are without
any further ado let me just uh get
started with the presentation so before
i really tell you guys about uh the
future of big data let me just uh for
the benefit of all let me just introduce
you uh to what is uh you know big data
introduction to big data as a concept
and then carry on from there so um i'm
sure you must have definitely heard
about uh you know big data as a concept
as a technology uh you know as as data
uh definitely amongst your friends in
your organization you know the
interviews that you would have been uh
you know giving and things like that so
what is big data uh the other day i was
giving this presentation uh in one of
the virgin online sessions and one of
the uh participants asked me uh you know
is it about size it is about volume is
it about speed is it about accuracy what
is it about
and what i told him is that and where
does the game begin how big is big data
so what i told him is that
you know
what do you usually work work on do you
work on a laptop
he said yeah laptop desktops so i asked
him
how much is the size of the hard disk
you know that your laptop or a desktop
has
uh he said
a terabyte of
disk hard disk or two terabytes of disk
as far as laptop is concerned or four
terabytes of disk as far as my desktop
is concerned
is it amazing uh the size of data uh
that your computer cannot hold it's
beyond the capability of your individual
computer to hold that data to store that
data it is where the game begins um and
and by that token of logic we can
definitely say that
uh somewhere around somewhere around you
know five terabytes of data is where the
game begins which is where saving it on
your individual machine uh becomes a
really uh you know really big challenge
um really big challenge uh so and guys
uh as richard said uh you know and
towards the end of the presentation
we'll have 15 minutes of a question
answer session so just if you have
questions in mind i'll i know that you
guys would have enough and plenty of it
so just hold back uh let me just go
through the content and then uh you know
at the end of it you guys can um you
know go ahead and ask your questions uh
and and mind you uh me and richard
don't leave any questions uh that you
post and you you might queries that you
might really be having
uh so there you go uh you know on the on
the on the concept part uh back to the
content of the uh of the presentation uh
and as i was talking about big data so
yeah so any data which your individual
computer cannot hold right and let's
talk about the best case of desktop
right four terabytes of uh you know disk
five terabytes is really we can safely
say that this is where your game begins
isn't it
if this is where the game begins that
means the very first thing that this big
data you know the very first challenge
of this big data imposes or throws in
front of you is that uh it's about the
storage right
let me just show it to you you know just
listed down over you uh you know in
front of you over here storage like how
do you store it if your individual
computer cannot save it then how would
you store it right so storage is a big
problem
and it's a it's a problem which is nice
to have because if you can store this
data properly um and and you know as you
will see as i'm gonna kind of you know
tell you that
more and more organizations have started
considering data as uh you know
something which is uh which is a which
is an asset just like you know any other
physical or um you know soft asset that
your organizations might have
you know that this is an asset you know
that if you can store it you know well
you can definitely
you know make use of it so storage is a
big challenge you know first of all
secondly if you're able to store it
properly the second challenge that you
come across is you know how you process
it because that is your ultimate aim
isn't it if you can process this data
in a meaningful way get some you know
crazy insights get some amazing insights
up you know out of it you can basically
make some decisions you and you know you
and your organization can make you know
some some really interesting decisions
and really uh you know if i may call it
game changing decisions um you know as
far as you know their business or as far
as their competition is concerned
so the storage is a challenge and then
if at all you're able to store it
properly
and nicely then processing is another
challenge
right so big data as
you know as we are coming to understand
it because of its share size the sheer
humongous you know size of it um storage
is a problem and then processing on top
of it is again a bigger problem there
are other aspects to big data um you
know
sometimes you will feel that uh you know
the data is coming at a very very fast
speed as i'm gonna be you know telling
you in one of my points uh that you know
in future you will see that this speed
become will become faster and faster as
the volume would grow the speed also
will become faster and faster in next
you know upcoming years and that is
where a lot of opportunity uh life or
you know professional uh like you are so
anyways more on that a little later
storage and processing that's what the
business is anyways
right so
let's go and understand you know what
are the technologies which help you um
you know take care of these two you know
challenges well you would have heard
about this technology hadoop and its
associated ecosystem
that is what provides this solution for
these two big challenges right storage
and processing right uh so apache hadoop
it's a it's a it's a it's an open source
software
from the apache community
uh it is the software which basically
provides the solution for these two
challenges let's go ahead and find out
how does it provide the solution to
these two challenges that i've just now
mentioned
to you guys in front of you let's
understand apache hadoop in detail a
little bit detail and in in the regards
of these two challenges that i have
mentioned to you uh you know just now
amazing very good so that's what we are
that's where we are the definition is
written over here right in front of you
let me just arrange my screen a little
bit so that i can get a little bit of
real estate uh to see um
how we are doing and show the screen
properly to you about this part now let
me just push it a little uh a little uh
below so that you don't get distracted
amazing that's where you are apache
hadoop is an open source framework right
it's an open source framework
um
what do you mean by open source open
source is a software which has certain
characteristics isn't it it's uh it's
free of cost
open for the community uh to play around
with it there are no licensing
conversations to it to it you can kind
of just you know pick it and and and
start using it
and there's also a very huge community
support for it there's a very huge
community base which supports it right
so it's an open source framework
what is the framework let me let me keep
on emboldening these you know important
words in this definition
as as we move on right to make it really
interesting to make it really
interesting it's an open source
framework what is the framework what is
the framework a framework a framework is
those
those pre-developed pre-processed
pre-tested libraries
uh which which basically are provided to
you off the shelf so that you can use it
in your program and what is the
functionality that these these
pre-tested be developed libraries uh you
know encompass they have in themselves
these functionalities are you know those
repetitive mundane
you know administrative
uh you know work that you would code
that you would always want to write in
your you know in your in your program
and you will see you will see yourself
you know keep on repeating it all the
time right i'll give you a couple of
examples to make it simpler for you uh
transactions
security
logging right
this is the kind of thing that you would
always want to do in your in your
in your programs so framework is is that
kind of you know that kind of libraries
which makes your life easier right now
if a party hadoop is an open source
framework let's go ahead and understand
what does it provide
right what does it provide what is it
that it is providing to us right so it
is meant to provide an automated
distributed computing environment
it is meant to provide us an automated
distributed computing environment now
what is distributed computing
environment for those of you who would
have worked in distributed computing
environment manually should i say
would know the pains and perils of
distributed computing environment right
10 different machines one of the machine
going down the other machine crashing
you having to make sure that you replace
with the bad machine with the good
machine you making sure that the
processing that was already done on the
bad machine the crash machine is
replaced by a good machine and the
processing starts from exactly the point
where the
uh the processing stopped at the time
when the machine crashed too much of a
hassle too much of a problem too many
things for you to handle on your own
manually wherein you are here in this
environment where you want to do some
analytics where you want to do some
analyze analysis you don't want to spend
your time in thinking about all these
administrative stuff right this has to
be provided by some kind of framework
but this has to be provided by some kind
of
open source framework isn't that make it
even more attractive to you that's
exactly what hadoop framework does for
us it is an open source framework which
provides the automated distributed
computing environment to us it says that
if you have got ample amount of
resources available in your cluster i am
going to make sure that if one of your
machine crashes
i am going to replace the bad machine
with the good machine i am going to make
sure that whenever the good machine is
available i am going to start the
processing exactly from the point where
it stopped when the machine crashed and
then lots and lots of other facilities
lots and lots of other services lots and
lots of other administrative mundane and
repetitive services so that you as a
developer you as a business analyst can
concentrate only on exactly what why
you're here for you are here for do your
business to do your business analytics
right and that's exactly you know what
uh what you concentrate upon exactly
amazing excellent we got uh you we got
uh
we got uh we got a bit of you know we
got a bit of uh we got a bit of uh uh
you know idea about it um and uh then um
just so once again
a little bit down so this is what it is
um so
how does it provide the solution to the
above two uh big data challenges how
does it provide the challenge the
solution to the above two big data
challenges it provides something called
as hdfs hadoop distributed file system
which basically um yeah you know stores
big data thing and then it provides uh
uh it provides a a
a framework called as mapreduce
which basically helps you process that
data right hdfs is something which is
based on uh which is based on uh which
is based on a white paper by google
called gfs google file system and map
reduce is based on another
white paper by google called as
mapreduce algorithm
right so two problems you know in front
of you uh which
with two challenges in front of you uh
with big big data uh you know uh imposed
in front of you and those two problems
got solved by a big data as a as a you
know as a concept
by by hadoop as a as a framework
excellent so brief background on what
the framework you know looks like
let's just go back and uh and and to
just let's just go back to the list of
you know things uh you know let's list
up the content and see what of all
things we have completed the
introduction is fine uh introduction to
big data is fine
uh challenges which is fine available
solution hadoop is fine and quickly uh
before moving on to the points on uh you
know future of big data i'll just
quickly run a hadoop program and show
you uh how the program looks like
for you to get an idea about
about you know how the technology is
uh this is how uh you know the the
that's how you you kind of you know
interact with uh
with with with the software
and let's say i want another job over
here uh so you know i can do job like
this
you know i can basically you know pack
my uh you know package my program in
some kind of jar file i have some kind
of input file i've got some kind of
output file let's just go ahead and you
know uh uh
you know enter this program start give
job running and uh you know bingo there
you are you have a map reduce and loop
job running on on big data so um bit of
a background uh as far as the technology
is concerned uh let the job run it will
take some time for uh you know it to
complete while the job is running and
while uh you know it is getting
completed let's quickly move on to the
points uh you know of of the
presentation in terms of you know um
technology is fine we know that you know
big data you know has opportunities with
respect to it but you know where is it
going you know what is the future what
are the you know there you are the job
got completed so you know kind of you
know just give you a bit of idea about
you know what the technology looks like
um yeah so you know sample run uh there
you are i completed that as well uh the
future is big data right
quickly i'm kind of you know just uh you
know uh
moving on to uh the topic the main topic
uh so uh as as as i was telling you uh
you know about about the storage and the
size and the volume of big data um
what trend that you can expect in next
couple of uh in the next couple of years
would be um the volumes is going to you
know the volume is going to grow it is
going to get bigger and bigger if you've
been in big data and hadoop and it's
related associated technology for some
time what you will feel what you would
have observed is that hadoop started
with
version 1.x where there's a concept
called as block size over there uh which
hdfs uses to divide your big data file
into different chunks
now when hadoop one point x started you
know at that time it was when hadoop
started
one point x the latest version initial
version the block sizes used to be at
that time 64 g 64 m
right 64 mb of block size then
you know time moved on industry matured
and then
the data becoming the data became you
know bigger and bigger huge and huge and
what what what people felt is that 64
mba of block size is too small for you
know big data to uh for for the for the
for the software to handle and that is
where uh that is where
the
the default block size of hdfs increased
at this point of time if you work in the
latest version of hadoop you'll see
that um
that
you know the block size is 128
and very few very near in future you
will see that this block size will will
increase even more
because the size of data is increasing
right um how to present version 2.x
right now if you really want to see what
the version is quickly you can jump to
the software and do something like this
over here
uh version
there you are
i do
2.7.2 very soon you will see that you
will have a
you know hadoop version major release
three point x
and that is where the block size is
something that is going to increase
because the data is increasing the data
is becoming huge the data is becoming
even more you know voluminous so you
need bigger block size so that hdfs can
handle it you know properly so that is
one thing that you can uh you know
expect um
you know huge data size and the block
size increasing in that regard amazing
that's the first point second thing is
the processing landscape is also
changing it's
changing pretty big time
uh what people have started thinking is
that mapreduce is something which is uh
which is a framework of choice uh which
is a part of part of hadoop
as a preferred technology to process
to process your big data but tap reduce
is something which is slow to process
um if you have a little bit of
background about what map produces the
technology is you would know that
mapreduce is is divided into two parts
the map part and the reduced part and
then when the mapper runs
it gives it throws an intermediate
output
on the machine in which the mapper
program is running and there are you
know in in the big data world in the
same you know in a simple big data in a
simple big data hadoop job you would see
that you know there are tens and
thousands of mappers running
now
each one of these mappers dumping output
on the individual machine on which the
mapper is running
if
if that is what your mappers are doing
writing the data on the
hard disk is something which is very
very performance inefficient
so there
has been a need of a framework which
basically can change can change these um
the the processing of these jobs and
that is where these new age frameworks
like uh spark and page are coming up
which is uh like a highly optimized
performance efficient uh processing uh
frameworks for uh big data
um if you've also been you know reading
a little bit about uh about big data and
it's related technology you would know
about some of the commercial commercial
uh softwares of of hadoop
like apache hadoop like cloudera for
example uh which is one of the industry
leaders in uh giving the commercial or
the professional versions of you know
hadoop wherein they give you uh you know
raw hadoop and then some additional
uh you know additional features on top
of it and you basically have to pay for
it and then um they uh you know provide
your service for you know a prolonged
period of time
and service for for a few period of time
now uh these commercial providers like
cloudera
like hortonworks
like map are
if you go to their website you will see
that they've already replaced their
processing part
right if they've already respect
replace the processing part with spark
the processing part no more has hadoop
in it no more has map reducing it right
so it is the beginning already
uh you know off of the chain that is uh
that is uh you know supposed to come
right so now let me just get back to
this night right so from mapreduce to
spark so spark is is one technology
which is is already been like you know
into uh big time into uh into uh
into uh the big data processing world
and something which is expected to pick
up
you know even uh
even uh you know in a major way so that
is one technology that you might want to
you know concentrate on
faster tools will be available to
process uh data like apartheid if any
one of you have
installed one of the hadoop ecosystem
component like hive or hbase for example
you will see
that you know when you install it now
and you install it on top of mapreduce
you will see a message saying that
migrate your hive to
a faster processing engine
either apache page
or spark or anything else but map reduce
because mapreduce is something which is
going to phase off very soon
right
that is that is that is an indication
enough which which means that you have
to move to um you know you know a faster
framework a faster framework a faster
processing engine right so that is
another you know another point to uh
note faster tools will be available to
do this and that is where your skills
that is where the skills will be needed
in the industry and that is where if you
upscale yourself in these uh these
technologies uh you would uh
you know you would be able to kind of
you know make the best out of it there
are other frameworks also like kafka for
example kafka is uh is an apache tool uh
which is uh which it does uh you know
messaging which provides provides
messaging framework for big data so if
you have
worked on messaging engines you would
know that you know your typical
messaging engine like your gravity mq or
your um
you know ibm ms mq
you know it it it works on a pop sub
model or uh you know publish uh
subscribe model but it it basically
passes data in a synchronous fashion uh
where the data payload is small in size
kafka is similar but the data over here
is bigger in size
right and kafka is another
framework which is you know
like you know continuously being uh
being upgraded and being kind of you
know uh worked upon
to kind of
you know
come up with faster and faster
processing uh of data against
asynchronous faster and faster closing
or big data is asynchronous fashion
so uh that is one more area where the
opportunity lies and your skills uh you
know might be uh might be useful
real-time streaming data uh is is also
something which is uh
is also something which is going to be
uh the future i was uh so i keep doing a
lot of consulting assignment and it was
recently in sydney where i was working
with one of the organization which was
uh basically into logistics um and uh
they had huge machines uh uh which were
you know carrying on uh carrying on and
off you know the
you know loads of uh uh
stuff from you know maybe from a
shipyard to um to a truck and then the
truck would carry on carry it on to you
know some location you know to to
offload it and these machines were
something which was connected to
computers and these computers are
continuously observing the the way these
machines work
and what they find is that
even if a couple of hours these machines
go down
they would incur you know heavy losses
so they wanted what they wanted to do
was that they wanted to continuously
monitor
the the you know
while these machines are operating while
these machines are
kind of
kind of you know doing their work if
they can continuously analyzing analyze
this data and preempt productivity
proactively what are the chances that
these machines can can can can you know
fail in future and how likely and when
they are supposed they are expected to
fail in future they can take some
contingency measures uh you know well
ahead in time so that you know they have
a you know stock gap arrangement uh you
know available to them so that is what
is the streaming data where you
continuously analyze the data uh you
continuously store the data and analyze
it and keep on you know looking for
patterns uh so that you can uh you know
in case of any contingency in case of
any emergency you can quickly take some
stop gap measures uh so real time
streaming data now
one of the frameworks is basically deals
with real-time streaming data you have
got slew which is in the current uh
which is in the current um you know
which is in the current uh
apache ecosystem framework uh where
which is which is which is being
extensively used as far as the steaming
data is concerned in industry right now
you have spark has got a streaming
library which you can use um you know
for uh
you know for uh these kind of this kind
of streaming uh streaming application so
that is another technologies uh so uh
you know you know paul said and done
streaming is another area where uh where
where a lot of opportunity uh you know
lies as far as you know big data
in next couple of years is concerned so
um there you are uh as far as the job
role uh are concerned uh you know a lot
of people keep on asking me all the time
and you know has big data lost as she
and uh like it's just you know another
fad
you know are there really opportunities
available uh you know what are the kind
of rules which are available in the
industry what i've seen the trend is
that uh the organizations since you know
organizations are storing almost
anything that they are generating out of
their systems uh they need people to
manage it they need people who can take
responsibility in managing that data
um so you know roles like chief data
officer chief exe chief information
officer
is is is something which is going to be
you know upcoming and that is where uh
you could see that in next three to four
years those are the kind of roles which
are going to be uh you know which are
going to be available which are going to
be uh you know coming up
in abundance um more and more data
analytics professionals will be required
that is one more trend that i am
observing uh with all the clients that i
interact with uh the industry would look
forward to smooth the talent crunch as i
said i keep going to
keep going and interacting with you know
global clients um i was recently in
sydney uh recently in europe as well
what i've seen is that uh you know these
these these uh you know these uh uh
you know countries uh these industries
they these domains they need a lot of
professionals but this is the dirt of
professionals uh you know well-trained
um you know knowledgeable experienced
professionals uh because
almost everybody wants to do something
with respect to big data something with
respect to analytics analysis of big
data so there's a dearth of uh you know
viewed earth resources and which is
where you working on these technologies
which i've just now mentioned um you
know spark tage
um kafka um you know streaming and scar
in spa is something that is going to be
you know kind of kind of you know very
very uh useful so big data much more big
data analytics when i say big data
analytics professional
you know covers uh you know everything
so you know data science data scientists
hadoop developers um
you know people who can you know manage
these projects people who can architect
and design these kind of projects is
also
you know something which is going to be
uh which is going to be you know needed
uh data as a service model uh is also
something uh that will be needed i was
recently reading a case study where i uh
uh where i
you know organizations like uh
like sun uh institute in us uh
you know they they
they collect the data and then they sell
it um to you know various uh you know
health organization tfi dfir for example
tata institute of fundamental research
is one of the you know clients for uh
you know institute which is basically um
you know provides medical and health
data um which uh which which you know
the you know these these these
organizations buy it and then use it for
their own research uh you know something
like something like a you know cancer
research or you know decide for
alzheimer's or
look for patterns dna sampling and those
kind of things
so uh
data being sold as a service another
trend that you can uh see upcoming uh
upcoming in in in in future
algorithm as a service model is another
wonderful thing that uh that you know i
have seen uh you know uh you know
emerging you would have definitely uh
been knowing about these websites like
algorithmia data foo giggle these are
the website which uh
we basically sell uh you know algorithms
now people know that they have data
people know that they have stored it uh
uh but then you know they have got two
choices one is develop the processing
that develop the code around it
themselves or go ahead and buy it which
is a faster option so these are the
organizations which i've just listed
them you know a few few of them over
here these are the organizations which
basically are are the ones uh which
which sell code which you can kind of
you know buy it bring it into your
environment and then
depending upon your requirement
depending upon your uh your need your
situation you can customize it you can
you know by by professionally uh you
know
get get the support for it and then use
it for
your uh you know your
basically
you know your analysis uh so
algorithm as a service model is also
something which is going to pick up and
you know these are the companies
i've seen that
these are the companies are you know
springing up uh like anything um you
know
you can go and join there you can you
know create as you can develop product
and you know as uh as uh algorithms as
product and then these organization can
sell it and market it and and you know
then the the the client in the customer
customers custom customers can use it
so now you know that is another uh you
know other another you know aspect to it
there are actually lots and lots of them
i've just listed a few important ones
and you know for uh you know for your
reference give me one second guys
uh yeah a few important ones for uh your
reference just once again yeah just
arranging my stream um
uh what else fast and exchangeable data
will be required uh um you know
if if you know a little bit about the
data scientists and and the job profile
you know that you know data scientists
work in tools like r in tools like w uh
you know in tools like pagan hive and
their primary uh their primary the job
responsibility is to uh is to
continuously keep on mining the data and
keep on looking the trends um you know
maybe sample the data and then you know
keep on looking for the trend and people
looking for the areas which are
uh best suited for analysis
right uh but uh and and then go to the
business right and that's how it works
in any business analytics project
whether it's you know data warehousing
which also is a kind of business
analytics
area or whether it's big data on you
know
the volume the volume of data that we
are talking about
and you'll always see that these guys
would uh you know mine the data they are
going to you know come up with the area
they're going to come up with uh you
know with uh these uh
you know these these right set of
questions
uh you know these these right set of
questions which
basically would be worthwhile analyzing
and pursuing um in terms of
the technological exploration so let's
say that okay maybe you know this is the
product uh which we should concentrate
upon this is the business strategy that
we should concentrate upon the business
will take that up and um you know give
it to the technical team technical team
will use this uh you know this setup of
these you know
this you know a garment of uh
you know technical implementation
analyze it quickly and then come back to
you and uh and and and
and give you uh the clear picture of it
so uh you know fast and exchangeable
data
more than big data is something that is
going to be you know the need of the er
so that these data scientists can
quickly analyze it can quickly mine it
and quickly come up with these uh these
uh you know meaningful uh insights um
rather than just
storing everything if
the organizations would be looking to
store something which can be easily
analyzed which can be easily mined which
can easily give them a direction to move
on so that their time to market their
speed becomes uh becomes faster
so um these are the other two things
that
that you know we can concentrate upon
and last but not least
machine learning machine learning is
also something which is going to um you
know pick up in a big way in next um you
know um you know upcoming years
uh if you don't know what machine
learning is i'll just give you a give
you a couple of examples uh i'm sure you
know most of you will have your uh when
you have your uh you know email ids uh
uh created and you know most of you will
have your you know the emails uh created
in google email which is which is gmail
and you would see that you know from
last you know an year or so there are
different categories with by default
come in in your email right so you know
whether you you you and basically it
categorizes your email as it comes
so whether it's your email is uh
is is your main email or your social you
know in the category of social uh uh
you know area or in the promotional area
or you can add labels uh of your own so
that is what is machine learning where
uh the system uh on its own uh decides
uh you know what kind of uh what kind of
an email is that and then accordingly uh
send it up to the relevant section
relevant label and then over a period of
time as you keep you know telling that
system that you know this is my main
email or this is my social email or this
is my promotional email it keeps on you
know learning more and more so more and
more feed that you give to it the you
know better that algorithm becomes
uh so that is one it's basically called
as you know a classification type of
machine learning there are other types
of uh you know machine
learning areas as well you've got
something called as uh uh you know uh
something called as
uh group based so you would have seen
that uh in
in
in in your google news right
uh depending upon which category your
news is if it is from technology or the
top story or health or business and
finance
um you know automatically uh google
keeps on segregating it based on what
machine learning algorithm uh you know
you have uh you have written uh so um
you know you know
a spark let me kind of you know give you
a technical back you know aspect to it
spark for example has a machine learning
library which you can uh which using
which you can use uh
you can create your own algorithms
for your own uh you know unique
situations uh and and and then basically
over a period of time as the more and
more data comes you can uh you can keep
on customizing it can keep on uh
improving itself uh uh on the basis of
uh on the basis of the data and on the
basis of the actions that you take upon
this data so um yeah machine learning is
another area which is going to be um
you know very very sought after skill uh
in in
in the upcoming years
and as i said the frameworks like spark
remotes like mongodb uh and and
frameworks like um you know like
cassandra is something which is going to
be a very very uh you know a useful and
instrumental um in in doing this kind of
research there are lots of lots of other
points uh you know i can keep going on
and on but i think um you know i should
stop over here i hope uh these uh you
know 10 or 11 points that i have
presented uh in front of you
give you a bit of idea about um you know
where the industry is going as far as
you know big data and its
associated technologies uh you know are
concerned
uh the future is bright uh the future is
great uh if right now is the time that
you were deciding to uh you know get
into it uh to kind of you know start
learning the skill
this this is the right time
uh on that note uh i would just hand it
over to richard to hand it back to
richard and uh we can take up the
questions
excellent say
uh
great i love the talk
uh let's go ahead and you have some
great questions here
before i start the questions i'm gonna
go ahead and bring up a poll
and then they can answer the poll while
we're doing a qa
and is everybody hearing me okay i had a
little feedback there for a second
okay uh so i'd say you definitely went
over the the number one questions what's
the job opportunities in hadoop
um i was going to just add on to that a
little bit if i was going to take
let's see the most easiest route to get
into hadoop what kind of training or
certification would you suggest
uh if it was like just an entry level
um
richard uh i think that uh see hadoop as
a technology is something which is
developed in java
uh so uh the first and foremost thing is
if if an individual is uh
is uh you know preferably having some
kind of java background
it is the it is very easy it it's
relatively easier for him or her to pick
up the technology
uh but nevertheless the courses that you
know the simply learn offers has a
module
called as
called as java for java essentials for
big data which is a very easy kind of
easy to understand module which within
which if even if the person doesn't have
the java background uh you can easily
pick it up and and and and you know take
these courses so the starting point
would be
you know java as a programming language
and then doing a big return hadoop
course
if the person does not have the java
background you can and if you have one
programming background at least one
programming background that that then do
it is fine
um
but at least one programming background
one programming knowledge but
programming language background is
definitely required to get up and going
in this
now hopefully i was able to answer the
question
oh that was great um i have also another
question here from uh p konar i hope i'm
saying that right
uh oh
i guess it's pulak
a mathematician
who works with data science
looking for special courses and
to get a job in the data industry so
he's already a profession a professor
in mathematics and wants to take that
into the big data industry what would
you be your suggestion for him
uh mathematician statistics uh by the
way i'm a statistics graduate but
i just kind of you know thought it's
worth mentioning mathematics and
statistics is the best background to
start up you know the working big data
and it's rated technologies
uh the way the route to go for you conor
would be not through hadoop
not through uh any programming language
to start with the better route for you
to go would be through uh some kind of
uh
data scientists uh
data scientist software data analysis
software i should say so something like
um you know r for example our
programming language uh doing a course
in our programming language with some
kind of statistical background is
something which is going to be uh very
very useful for you there are commercial
software's also available so you've got
something called as tableau
but i mean to kind of you know sum it up
i would say that
you already have a mathematics
background give us give some flavor of
statistics to it
uh you know add to that a technological
uh
you know
data scientist uh tool like r and w do
us do some course like that
uh which i'm sure simply learn
definitely would have um and and that is
the way to go data scientist is your
area uh you know
excellent i hope that thank you thank
you i hope that answered that question
on there uh some other great questions
let me just go back down here
i'm going to skip one until we're done
with the poll because they want you to
redo one of the slides
and then i have a question from saranya
how do i become a big data trainer how
do you how did you become a data uh you
know doing the educational side syed
all right so okay that's a very good
question very close to my heart
um
first of all uh trainer is something you
can become when first of all you need to
have a flare of speaking now you should
like speaking that's the very you know
basic minimum requirement you should
have the stamina for uh to keep speaking
for a couple of hours you know three
hours four hours five hours at times
secondly um
you should have a very sound knowledge
uh the basic fundamental knowledge
because that goes without saying uh
people you know come in in these
sessions where they
want to understand the basic they want
to understand the fundamentals of the
technology and the third most important
thing which people look uh about a lot
is
you know how much practical experience
you have so being a trainer you cannot
have a union dimensional profile where
you just remain a trainer you keep like
what i keep doing i keep doing a lot of
consulting project i keep traveling all
across the world keep meeting different
different clients keep getting myself
into different different scenarios
and then whatever experience i get from
this consulting project i keep sharing
it in my sessions
uh so i would say three things to sum it
up you know flare for speaking uh very
solid core fundamental knowledge and
practical exposure if you have these uh
three things you are you know up and
running for it
night richard
yes oh that sounds great i was too busy
listening
i forgot that's supposed to be on the
other end uh we have some more questions
coming
uh let's see we have
uh sandeep asking
why hadoop block size is more like
128 megabytes compared to other
platforms more technical side of it
yeah something it's because data is so
huge as i was mentioning in the starting
of uh very very beginning of the
presentation i said that uh you know the
game big data starts at up at terabytes
you know five terabytes ten terabytes
and um
you know
i usually go into in a lot more detail
in my session but uh you know what i
would like to kind of you know give you
an up an idea about is that
the way hdfs stores data is in terms of
blocks uh so uh you uh when you save a
big data file in hdfs it divides
immediately it's write that immediately
into blocks of 128 mb of size by default
which by the way is also customizable
you can change it according to your
requirement but 128 mb is something
which is which is kind of you know just
just just
just about right the other important
aspect is that these programs this
analytical program that you write in
spark and in mam produce is something
which works on these blocks
so if this blocks are too small uh these
programs would have would have nothing
great to do if these blocks are too uh
huge these programs will keep running
forever
so at this point of time with this with
the state that the with the state in
terms of the volume that big data is 128
mb is just about
the you know optimal size as i said the
data the future is where the data is
going to go it is going to become huge
so it's pretty much sure that you know
when the three point x uh version comes
in this p 128 mb will become 256 mb and
then the live goes on the show goes on
like that so that's that's about the
logic behind it uh
and and something that that's what might
take uh you know on it on that
oh nice
thank you um i've got a question from
and i hope i say the name right uh
subrenzit has a couple questions
i am not familiar with freder's
guideline uh but wondering about
starting a career in analytics analytics
specific to
fredder's guideline and aspects of
fretters and analytics as of now
what are the aspects for that as a
career right now um
sorry
can you say that again i didn't get it
um you know i'm
it has to do with the freder's guideline
or fresher's guideline i'm not sure what
that is
okay i see your spelling error and then
down below okay
i i got it i got it i got it this is
right
right super anjeet
yeah
uh i tell you what subranjeet um you
know i keep telling this to all my you
know participants and attendees who come
in my presentation there are two things
three things you know basic that you
require as a fresher to start your
career in analytics right now
number one
have a very very solid programming
background very solid programming
background you know c c plus plus
python or java uh definitely one of
these if both of them nothing like it so
the first thing is have a very very
solid programming background number one
number two uh
have uh you know
you should have some big data technology
course done so simply not as i keep uh
as i've been mentioning as richard i've
also been mentioning this
as a wonderful course uh big data in
hadoop course
one such course you should definitely do
to get all the fundamentals and all the
practical aspects of uh of big data and
hadoop so that's the second thing that
you should do and the third thing that
you should do is
that you should do one certification
um you know simply not has one you know
the course actually you know culminates
in doing certification uh which is also
very well recognized in the industry
so that is one thing another thing is
that you can you you should go for uh
a
a professional certification like cloud
era for example and my fourth uh option
is related to that
uh the fourth you know guideline is
related to that see what happens in
cloudera certification right now is that
you know it's no more an mcq question
you know kind of thing you have you will
go there they'll give you a couple of
use cases and then they'll give you a
data set and then they'll say that okay
this is a data set this is this is the
environment and then go ahead and go
ahead and implement these use cases on
this environment and using this data set
so it's all hands-on
so what you should actually do is that
you know as a fourth guideline i mean
there's a third guideline you should
definitely prepare for the certification
and give them that is going to boost
your profile
and the fourth guideline what you should
do is that you to have this kind of
environment ready on your system
wherein uh you know i'll tell you about
my system my system has
you know hadoop hive
uh phloem scoop everything uh ready uh
and if i go and meet my consultants uh
you know i go and tell them that
they give me scenarios i tell them okay
you give me a couple of hours i'll go
ahead and implement that for you
uh and and you know almost nine out of
ten times i end up getting the project
so have that environment run you know
running on your machine whenever you go
for interview go and meet your
interviewer you know tell them the
fundamentals which you anyway know and
ask him for use cases and implement it
for him right then and there there is no
reason why anybody can
cannot hire you
these are the four things that i can
suggest to you my friend subranjeet
excellent excellent i think that also
answered some of the other questions
that were coming up i'm going to go
ahead and in the poll and maybe you
could once i give you back the screen
there was a question on if you could
where was it uh rerun
one of the slides on the running the
hadoop
i can definitely do that uh richard do
you want me to do that
uh yes go ahead and do that and then
hopefully after that we'll have a time
for maybe one or two more questions and
before we close the session oh yeah
this is something that i love doing you
know
let me just show you a couple of
commands quickly so this is one of the
hdfs commands um which basically tells
you give you the view of hdfs so there
you are i have done one program quickly
over here i didn't get into much of the
details because the topic of the
presentation was not really hadoop it's
just kind of you know skim through it
but you know a couple of commands here
um
you know you can you can delete this
folder uh uh you know by this command oh
i didn't mention about my blog also so
i'm going to mention about my you know
blog as well i i write a blog where i uh
write instructions about you know how to
do all these instructions i'm just going
to share it with you all
uh so basically what this program does
is that it runs the runs of word count
program from the uh you know from the uh
from the software installation so this
is my hadoop software installation uh
you know on my mac let's go here
and this is one of the libraries in
which all my examples are there
right and i'm using one of the files
called test.txt and this is the output
folder so if i go here and say that you
know hadoop
f s dash cat and say test dot txt
um it is going to give me an output like
this which is that
will say that
this is a demo demo obsession some some
some words over there and what happens
is that when i'm going to uh you know
run my program over here um you know
it's basically going to analyze it and
it's going to find out the count of the
num
number of the count the unique words you
know over here so this is one what is
one you know one map reduced program
which is running in front of you in a
very small fight i usually run it on a
big data file also but it takes a while
to uh to run
uh so yeah there you go the program is
running you know i've been fine uh while
this program is running i'm just going
to quickly pick up my uh uh my blog link
and share it in front of you
put it up in front of you and share the
link also with all of you all uh
if i can do that let me see
with the chat window to the entire
audience there you go this is my blog
link uh it has the instructions to you
know uh to uh to install hadoop to you
know run it
you know you can go through you know all
these instructions and do installation
of your own basically when you do that
installation you end up getting this
kind of output quickly if you want to if
i want to show you the output of how it
looks like i can say that fs ls in fact
let me say
let me say ls and say output
it's basically going to give me an
argument like this
which is just
too cool i'll say r dash r dash one two
three four five
and say cat over here
and is basically going to give me an
output which says that
you know what you have entered demo four
times and this one time and a one time
and also so basically you know this is
how um
programs run
right uh richard
excellent um i i have fun playing with
that too i love watching the script go
down there and then pulling up the
answer
we have a c a couple time for maybe one
or two more questions uh one of them and
i can't find the original question
was uh what other
systems are there that are outside of
the hadoop file system for big data
what's what's this competition look like
uh
the competition actually at this point
of time is you know with hadoop it's
mainly with spark uh who was that
richard
who was asking this question ah you know
i'm looking for the original question um
we've got a lot of good questions on
here and it was a ways back
uh but i think that was mainly open
source is there any other open source
because i know spark can also run on its
own
i think mongodb can do its own clusters
but it can also sit on the hadoop file
system and there's a few others or is
those those are the ones i know
yeah so yeah definitely yeah and thanks
for sharing that uh richard uh yeah
definitely uh spark is one and spark is
a complete stack uh you know basically
uh it doesn't basically requires hadoop
to run it can run on its own as you
rightly said
richard
then
you have
this one more thing which i was going to
mention
um
see the thing at this point of time is
that you know you have competition
mainly in terms of the commercial
softwares of hadoop so you've got cloud
era you've got uh you know map or you've
got hortonworks as i was suggesting and
the competition is really between these
you know three or four major players
um
with hadoop
you know technology per se uh there are
options available which are basically i
would say better better frameworks so
analytical frameworks like for example
you have got sas
which is which is which is very good
but the problem with these you know sas
terror data the problem with these
frameworks is that they are not open
source they come from a premium
uh the main reason why hadoop as a
technology and spark and as a technology
is picking of big time is because uh
their cost effectiveness i mean they
actually don't you don't have to spend
anything in buying the software
um so to answer your question i would
say that the the options are really in
terms of
the commercial
you know
uh commercial
distributions um
plain raw hadoop
i don't see there are any uh any real
competition any real competition coming
up over there apart from spark as you
said richard
oh excellent i know spark runs on the
hadoop file system quite well i think
one of the original people in spark
was one of the developers in hadoop is
that right
uh sorry say that again
oh i believe one of the original
developers of spark one of the main
people behind it and i can't think of
names uh it was also one of the main
people behind setting up the hadoop file
system and also it goes all the way back
to the
google file system that hadoop evolved
out of is that right
do you mean duck cutting
yes yes
duck cutting mike cafarella and these
are the old guys uh cutting by the way
richard is working with cloudera right
now
and he is uh he's teaming up with uh one
of the guys who has been who's known as
uh
who's known as the uh father of the
modern day uh data warehousing concept
um i don't remember his name uh uh
uh sorry was it parmender
no uh his name starts with r uh it's not
striking me uh
and
no no okay not repair she's he's
somebody completely different
i'm just trying to throw out our names
i'm getting in trouble now
yeah
it's actually not richard kimball yeah
kimbala it's actually ralph
yeah
so he and duck cutting are together
doing some crazy work in cloudera at
this point of time now you know i keep
following them you know
a lot
yeah i know
i was able to answer the question uh
richard
yeah so that was wonderful yes um i do
believe we're at the end of this session
uh let's go ahead and close this session
now
i want to thank everybody for being here
uh greatly appreciate it uh happy
learning to everybody
and there will be a i can't remember no
there's not a closed question after this
one it's the other one that has a close
questionnaire
and we already did the quick
questionnaire on this one
uh well thank you syed i really
appreciate it it's a great uh session i
really enjoyed it
thank you so much you this was my
pleasure
and i was enjoying it so much that i
felt like going on and on but i have to
stop somewhere isn't it
i understand
thank you so much and thank you so much
everyone else and um hope to see you
guys soon in one of my sessions
excellent happy learning day everybody
thank you bye bye take care and have a
good uh have a good time god bless bye
you